نحن الان نقف في منزل عائله الكيلاني الذي
الذي تعرض لمجزره اسرائيليه موثقه وهذا
المنزل هو الشاهد الحقيقي على هذه المجزره
قتل بعض افراد العائله بشكل مباشر من قوات
الاحتلال بالاضافه الى الرصاص الذي تناثر
بين اجساد المواطنين الذين يسكنون هذا
البيت بالاضافه الى القذائف والقنابل
المتفجره الذي التي تعرضت لها هذه العائله
قتل بعض الافراد وبقي بعضهم احياء وقت
ادان الفجر
صار اطلاق نار كثيف علينا على البيت واحنن
ناس مسالمين يعني فكرنا انه شي عادي لقينا
الرصاص والقذائف بتخش علينا في البيت
فتوجه الحج لمنا كلنا شردنا في الغرفه
اللي موجوده هناك تقريبا 50 شخص فصارت
القذائف تخش علينا زي ما انت شايف قنابل
قويه جدا فالحج يعني 50 نفر طلع معه شريطه
بيضاء يقول لهم انه احنا اطفال وناس
مدنيين فما ما كملها فكانوا مطلقين عليه
الرصاص اردوه قتيلا على بنفس الوقت يعني
وكان ابني وراه طفل عمره 12 سنه قام بضربه
بالقنبله طلعت الله يعزك احشاءه
بالخارج زوجتي بتطلع على ابني اللي
مستشهد فقام بطخه برصاصه بظهرها طلعت من
بطنها دخلت في رجل ابني هنا 50 غرزه في
رجله وشديه القنابل ه في راسه وفي ايده
طبعا وفي وفي رصاصه هنا مدخل ومخرج
احنا كرجال نزلونا تحت عرايا كاملين يعني
ما حتى بدون ملابس داخليه ونمونا في
الحاصل تحت وم عارفين ايش اللي صار ومش
عارفين مين اللي
مات ف اثناء انه نزلوا النسوان شفت انا
زوجتي بتنزف دمه فيش سيارات اسعاف ولا في
حاجه ونحنا ما قادرين نعمل لهم شيء طبعا
ابوي وابني ماتوا على في نفس الوقت يعني
ماتوا
استشهدوا ف اخدونا تحت وطب تعذيب فينا
وطلعوا على العماره احتلوها زي ما انت شفت
كيف سووا في العماره طبعا احنا ناس امنين
لا نا في مقاومه ولا نا في
حدا ورجونا من البيت فقتد ي انا وابني
منطقه ساحليه على البحر طبعا بعد ما
اخذونا على الجامع اتقوني انا وابني
الصغير 18 سنه وا خذونا على منطقه
ساحليه وانا اطلق صراحه ثاني يوم تقريبا
الفجر وابني لحتى اللحظه اللي ننا بحكي لك
فيها مفقود ما بعرف عنه حاجه هذه اثار
القنبله الاسرائيليه التي القتها قوات
الاحتلال على عائله الكيلاني قتل على اثر
هذه القنبله عدد من افراد العائله في حين
ان قوات الاحتلال اعدمت الحاج من هذه
المنطقه ومن هذه
الزاويه قوات الاحتلال تعتمد سياسه القتل
والتخريب والاعدامات الميدانيه وثقت مجزره
عائله الكيلاني لكن هناك الاف المجازر
التي لم توثق اسماعيل الغول الجزيره مدينه
غزه y